this security council meeting was called
by albania and the u.s there have been
persistent allegations that when russian
soldiers have captured areas of ukraine
they've taken away people who live there
to russia a process of enforced
displacement ambassador linda thomas
greenfield says the u.s government
believes the numbers involved are
staggering
russian authorities have interrogated
detained forcibly deported between 900
000 and 1.6 million ukrainian citizens
from their homes to russia
often to isolated regions
in the far east
and i want to be clear the united states
has information that officials from
russia's presidential administration are
overseeing and coordinating these
filtration operations
a senior human rights official says her
office can verify that what are known as
filtration camps have been set up to
process ukrainians but it's worth noting
she gave no estimate of the number of
people involved
ohchr has documented that men and women
perceived as having ties with ukrainian
armed forces or state institutions
or as having pro-ukrainian or
anti-russian views were subjected to
arbitrary detention torture
ill-treatment and enforced disappearance
they were transferred to penal colonies
including the now infamous penal colony
near olympnica olympic prison is the
place where 53 prisoners of war died
blown up in july russia says it was a
result of a ukrainian attack ukraine
says they were deliberately executed in
an explosion a u.n fact-finding mission
has been set up and is expected to visit
the site in the coming days
when he spoke in the security council
russia's ambassador said the meeting was
a new milestone in the disinformation
campaign by western nations he described
the people involved as refugees and said
his country is providing them with every
assistance
one of the world's leading human rights
organizations human rights watch says
its research shows that forced
deportation is taking place and it says
that amounts to a war crime
james bay's al jazeera at the united
nations